I'm not you are this stupid is you hear
me okay
you really want to get your channel shut
down you don't want any more rights but
you're black how could a black person be
a bigot not black I'm a white lesbian
this journey this road I travel on it
all seems crazy over the years I put the
files into Tagalongs inspired by my
story from a dream for now where my
clothes had holes in them
I'm afro is picky to the night east
maschino of Musashi ice no laces inner
Archie's new millennium I said I want a
home where I better care to better care
to the only thing brothers and sisters
there I think should be sisters and
brothers yeah
knowing others like you you know if your
review subscribe you know no I'm just
saying what if the person's no brother
or sister ah that's interesting cuz
that's what today's video is exactly
about bow and sisters we are going to
reaction to a black man who identifies
himself as a white lesbian being
confronted by a homosexual male man how
does it turn out let's watch for
ourselves and learn some important
lesson but before we start anyone that's
watching this we are not well we're not
asking you some disclaimers okay yeah so
the LGBTQ T for me to see what if it
maybe yeah this is a video that will
reaction to yeah so please no hate if I
have my right to freedom of speech I'm
not asking for anyone to be hurt I'm not
asking anyone to not have their
lifestyle except our religion is says
it's forbidden is haram simple as that
yeah but you can live your lifestyle so
this is just the video will react since
you so please before you send hate and
you know go on a mad one watch it and
understand where we're coming from
calm down ready get angry for Thamud
where do you find these videos listen
this videos find me
okay no no I'm ready
all right I'm ready look I'm not you are
the stupid is you feeling okay
[Music]
so what's your cards
what's your cause worse what's your
position I'm gay I am - okay they both
gave us - there's nothing wrong with
that
what does this light that say one man
and one woman I'm the happiest man in
the world why does your sign say one man
I went on a hundred percent gay why does
your sign say one man and one woman he's
the right man for we're okay so he's not
gay he's lying
yes why not why words are big words
don't mean anything today
turn around marriage always one man and
one woman so you're saying that gay
people can't get married I don't believe
in the special rights but you're glad
how could a black person be a begging
I'm not glad I'm a white house is before
by Steven yeah okay there's few things
he says so casually yeah yeah yeah this
is this interest video so he's saying I
don't believe in special rights I kind
of got it but let's watch a new educate
me if I've got if I've missed something
yeah so we're gonna find a why he's
claimed to be a white lesbian here I
mean a boy yeah boy could be a girl real
now you're making a mockery of my
research so why do do you believe them
that what about be for civil rights and
that black people a different out I know
was that wrong yeah it was legal no you
got your civil rights which is one oh
wait wait it was I just good point
why was he because he he makes a good
point that it was legal at that time
okay so he's basically saying that if
I'm a sexual is illegal today doesn't
mean it's right is this what he's trying
to say well it seems like he's gone that
way okay so that's the reason to give
the example this idea that did happen
yeah but it was legal
yeah so just because you are gay doesn't
mean it's right but it's legal
yeah or just because something's legal
doesn't mean that it's right I think
that's what Ron say okay this
with white lesbian oh thank you thank
you address me as a white lesbian I'm
not black a boy could be a girl and a
girl could be a boy so if I I'm not
black so if you talk to me you address
to me as a white list okay white lands
okay okay
okay interesting I've never seen a white
lesbian that's obviously a black male
now let's see how this white you know
you know in the teachers at school would
pause the video at just the right place
and it would choose everywhere and off
yes I think you've done that I never
seen a man that is gay based on science
I was born gay no oh what what what so
with the doctor said congratulations mr.
Johnson you have a five pound six ounce
what gay man gay male no cuz you're not
born a behavior I'm born Who I am I know
I look see I told you I'm a white
lesbian age you won't acknowledge me as
a white it's not scientific direct I
don't think the fact that you can be
born gay it's not I think that's what
he's saying he's saying is it so when
you're born there's the doctor say hey
biologically we have a game male that's
not scientific yeah that's what he's
referring to so that's a valid point
yeah it's me fair yeah okay
once again our opinions do not mean that
we don't make this claim because
sometimes he is he will just be real
here
yeah and I think artificially
intelligent you don't the same thing you
know who is making a mockery you you're
making a mockery you're offending this
community I don't think you've covered
your backside enough froggies you
apologize right and if we're talking
about science well scientifically I have
the right to say that actually no but
should should you not be offending
people though college students young
ones little ones weak ones but we got
freedom of speech
by the way yeah same thing its laws that
are based on hypocrisy and bigotry Nazi
Germany bacon no no you are no sir
you're you you're special you've changed
the definition of marriage only your
people can do that only your people only
gay people can change the definition of
marriage are they equal or special I'm
trying I'm the pennies drop in is he
trying to say you are asking for special
rights because biologically yeah and
well biological naturally and
scientifically the natural and chemistry
here well Olivia it isn't the messenger
Murphy is it is it a natural way that a
man and a woman
mister procreate yeah yet to procreate
let's be honest more violent for the
further for the survival of the mankind
is warrior even information even from an
evolutionary perspective yeah yeah it's
what was here who would be yeah think
about it to reproduce if if everyone was
homosexual yeah what would happen to our
our species then we'd be very good that
fashion it'll be the end of us right so
he's saying you're special to on special
treatment
am I wrong to say that probably are you
going to give some academically actual
video but I really I knew I should have
reacted this with are you special oh I'm
equal all human beings should be treated
equally not specially
sir so your reticular oh no you don't
have money you have boys actually made a
point about special and eco yeah would
you finger being bloody traitor no but
that's the thing she she responds with
you're ridiculous but he has made a
point okay what is that one okay the
game man there is no he just seems like
he's not he's the one who put this video
up which I would never for this video
because I think he got annihilated
Yannick with argument well yeah this not
this man the guy who's recording okay
everybody this guy made some very valid
points yeah what does he mean between
special he goes look I want equal rights
but I don't want people are asking for
special rights yeah yeah so special rice
is like me coming and saying I want to
be identified as a black watermelon yeah
a black watermelon boss in space that is
gender neutral bus say you have a very
okay no you don't have you see she's
self-defeating he stopped defusing
homonyms now yeah no no no he said oh
you enjoy a day white lesbian who is a
black Janna what this guy saying is you
know I'm a black male even if I identify
identify myself as a white lesbian the
fact that yours laughing at that is you
laughing at yourself yeah because you
can't come and say oh I was born gay I
was you can't do you get it you can't
ask people to identify you as that if
you are not acknowledged that I'm a
white lesbian do you get it
biologically yeah that's what yeah in
other words you're just saying it's a
contradiction he's making one push she's
expecting something not my bad
you're going with it yes exactly that
you're making a point by that same point
when it comes back to you it's
unacceptable exactly and we will stop
this nonsense it will fit over there are
than on you well it will get overturned
because you guys believe in the law so
when we overturn it you will accept it
right how is the black man how could you
be a little white lesbian so you telling
me a boy could be a girl is that
stupidity you're stupid
can a girl be a border you're the
stupidest man would we say that he's
spreading hate know and know people
might watch this and be like oh I know
that's hate was the LGBT community here
if you didn't want to pour arguments for
example incest if I said come on okay
what's wrong with a a son and a mother
having let's keep it civil yet by its
juice what could they see okay if we
said you know what they should instance
should be allowed whoa Ali I mean and
you know recently notice and recently
you know is it pedophilia it's trying to
you know they're trying to join the LGBT
movement they're saying except us this
is this is how we're born we're born as
pedophiles yeah there are people out
there so they're gonna be like no this
is disgusting well when somebody else
says that to the LGBT community is
bigotry when you say that to the Peter
father who says look I'm born this way I
can't help liking little kids do young
jealousy it's just a bad point I'm gonna
say no hate I'm not asking anyone to
hurt anyone I'm just saying that's my
right to freedom of speech and we're
just talking logically here that's all I
say you're a Muslim though you don't
have freedoms I'm sorry I do yeah and we
went to test our freedom of speech with
Mohammed each other and in return I will
so you can see you are the stupid
assuming okay I will hurry human
and I will you know love no one I will
love you until now true I won't live in
your hey people that are afraid of you
lied to know you spent hey there is no
gaijin what's the name of the gaijin ABC
what's the name of the gaijin what's the
name of the stupid genius called Johnny
no it's called whatever your name
why don't you post a video yeah so like
I didn't think the person who's
recording really understood like I'm
gonna be blue they keep calling the
other guy stupid but like I having some
intellectual arguments yeah and I don't
think they even grasp it and they put
the video up as if they were making a
point now the guy like I said before he
would say what guys share your thoughts
in the comment section here at the end
eh we're here just for provoking
reaction videos accident I'm not here to
spread any hate towards any kind of
community or two but I'm just trying to
speed the video whoa well yeah yeah so
Robin Sisters is any loss what you want
to say but often that was very very
thought-provoking and it made a lot of
sense
you know after is interesting because
sometimes when you disagree with
somebody to label somebody as stupid or
give them word yeah yeah it's it it
doesn't help your cause yeah your cause
the discourse or just thinking free
mainly mainly of course oh yeah those
ones you know it was actually made by a
Muslim there yup Oh invented the three
clothes what we love about smarter
Jenner this is what's so unique about
channel bond sisters do not forget to
unsubscribe to his channel subscribe
yeah so exactly because of that it
doesn't make sense I think even Dave
Chappelle made that point as well he
said that yeah when when he started
giving up his career to go to Africa
yeah people's I call him crazy and he
was on The Oprah Show saying just
because you don't under
stand what someone's going it doesn't
make them crazy because crazy saying
someone's crazy or stupid is dismissive
yes you're not you're not looking at the
argument you're too busy labeling them
because once you've labeled somebody a
terrorist stupid or a bigot or a fascist
or antifa
that's it or left or far right or what
whatever it when you put a label that's
it that's why people are so afraid of
label you miss apply it yeah I think
that's an accurate way of saying yeah
exactly I didn't they
it's and what's why are they seen that
the Dave Chappelle because today's
subjective world view him rejecting a
fifty million pound deal was like you're
crazy yeah no you're crazy because your
whole world is money to him it's not
anymore hmm
from sisters hope you guys benefited
help you if look if you're from the LGBT
community give us your feedback this is
with watch the video with reacted to it
we've seen both sides and once again
like I said before we're not here to
spend any kind of hate wasn't another
community at any laksa islamically under
the Sharia this is the land this is your
lands you can do whatever you like
Sharia law sheryn.low yes you know I
didn't there you can do whatever you
like we strongly it's very simple when
additional core religion it is a major
sin god almighty's destroyed nations
that have gone in those in the sin
however that was God Almighty we're not
here to do that by its very simple
promise sister so yeah give us your
thoughts in the comment section below
would they rather side knows you want
yeah whose side was you on comment in
the section yeah below whose side was
you